the staff of the Europa Park can see the
boss coming a long way off
everyone else drives a plane vehicle but
Holland Mack is in the Christmas more
beer and he's obviously having fun I
wouldn't have been able to do this for
44 years if I wasn't having fun if being
together with people always coming up
with something new putting new rides on
the market and watching children's eyes
light up and families having fun and
especially the international clientele
we don't just have German gas but like
the name says European guests that's a
big part of my life's work entitled mine
are leading South Garbo's just four more
days and the park will be opening for
the winter season it was lucky that the
weather turned cold enough so the
artificial snow won't melt right away mm
was the first year the europa park
opened in winter many people thought
holland mac was crazy to do it
saying it would only bring losses but
like a true businessman he took a
calculated risk on the quality to
maintain the quality and ultimately to
keep good employees on board we needed
to do business all year round and to
keep up the hotel's quality standards
and retain the chefs and specialists we
have of course opening in winter has
been a great benefit that wouldn't have
been dr. feelgood the hall and Mac
Empire includes five hotels with a total
of some 4,500 beds opening the park in
the winter keeps the occupancy rate at
around 80 percent
the biggest draw during the cold weather
is the shows
a special favorite is the ice review the
skaters are putting the finishing
touches on it
at last everything's ready for opening
day and the people come in droves
despite the cold who's going to be first
on one of the roller coasters the rides
have been certified safe in icy
conditions otherwise the measures taken
for the safety and security of the
guests are deliberately kept low-key
there are no uniformed personnel to
distract from the fun and carefree
atmosphere all the areas are decorated
in their own style well done it's great
it's like a dream and paradise they do a
lot for kids it's such a good feeling
the atmosphere is beautiful even a
winter wonderland has its price a
child's ticket cost more than 30 euros
for a day pass the calculated risk paid
off for Holland mock the winter season
has been turning a profit for years now
would be money so I understand you and
3,500 employees put so much effort into
it and invest so much money into fixing
the park up for Christmas it's so nice
to see the guests coming this atmosphere
has to have a solid business foundation
we get those subsidies it all depends on
the businesses economic feasibility or
any guests love winter in the Europa
Park they come back every year from all
over especially Germany France and
Switzerland